well the MP for Grantham in Stanford is
Nick Bowles who's been pushing a brexit
plan of his own I sat down with him and
started by asking him if he's going to
be backing the prime ministers deal it's
not a perfect deal I've had severe
reservations about it in the past
particularly the earlier version which
was going to carve Northern Ireland out
into a separate customs territory that's
not something that I think I would have
been able to vote for but actually I do
think that the latest version is is a
big improvement on that and of course
there are flaws of course there things
about it that I don't much like but I
certainly think that it is better than
no deal we do need to leave the EU in my
view so I will be voting for it and you
say you have some concerns about it I
mean those concerns are pretty widely
shared with lots of people in Parliament
on I mean the DP for example is saying
that they don't like the fact that
Northern Ireland will in their view be
treated differently to the rest of the
UK under the backstop others are unhappy
with the kind of close links to to the
EU or the fact that they think that the
future relationship is too flimsy a
release it's a real serious concerns on
them know there there are very serious
concerns and it is quite hard at this
point to see how the Prime Minister wins
because in the sense it's got into that
terrible position where lots of people
hate it for entirely different reasons
and that's not a very good place to be
if you're trying to win a majority in a
house where you don't have a permanent
majority oh it's gonna be difficult
isn't it I'm around a hundred
Conservative MPs who have expressed
opposition to the deal I mean there's no
way she's gonna get mr. e parliament is
that I think it's very unlikely that
she's going to win it's not completely
impossible I think that there has been
growing support I believe in the country
for the Prime Minister she's actually
been performing probably at her best in
the last few weeks and I think there's a
lot of public sympathy for the way that
she just keeps on going with all of
these people attacking her from all
sides same time that a few weeks not
very long I mean it's a bit too late
isn't it I think that's the problem in a
way I think it is probably too late to
turn it around if if in a sense the deal
had been announced a couple of months
ago
and she'd had the full two months to
talk to MPs individually to understand
their concerns to try and find ways to
address them maybe maybe maybe she could
have pulled it round but as it is I fear
she's not going to that she is going to
lose and then the question is what's
next well that is the question and you
have got a plan B haven't you just talk
you through what that is well I think
the most important thing about my plan B
is that it's nobody's plan a this is not
a perfect deal that I'm proposing but it
is the one that is doable what I'm
suggesting is that we should move into a
position a bit like norway's where we're
in the common market that binds Norway
Iceland and Liechtenstein with the EU
it's called the European Economic Area
and we join something called the
European free trade association and we
go into a temporary customs union with
EU until we've found new arrangements
that satisfy the border requirements to
the satisfaction of the Republic of
Ireland and the EU so we'd be in the
single market in a temporary customs
union but would be outside lots of
things that we don't like about the EU
would be a guide the common agricultural
and Fisheries policies would be outside
the European Court of Justice and would
be outside all of the political stuff of
the EU so it would be in a weird way
going back to the common market that we
joined you know decades ago that was
about trade and about economic
integration and we would no longer be
bound by this sort of drive towards ever
closer Union that the rest of the EU is
so committed to now it's one big problem
with your plan though isn't there and
that's immigration because if you do go
down the Norway route you have to accept
free movement of people I mean that
really is the Prime Minister's biggest
red line of all yeah the one big
downside there's no but avoiding it of
the Norway option is that freedom of
movement still applies now for many
people including many people in my
constituency and I'm very aware of that
the desire to control immigration was
one of the key motivations of their vote
to leave on the other hand the level of
Mayor migration from the EU is now at
its lowest level since 2012 just last
week we had the latest figures and we
also find in opinion polls that concern
about immigration has also subsided
quite fast but is that because they
think that free women it's going to end
well maybe tease or maybe it's because
they've seen that it is actually much
less of an issue than it was and there
is one thing about the European Economic
Area about the Norway position which is
that we would have this legal remedy
which is an emergency break which is
that if you have events that are causing
serious economic or societal
difficulties is the way it's put then
you can suspend one of the four freedoms
the freedom of movement for a period in
order to bring it under control now
nobody's used it and we don't exactly
know what it would deliver but it isn't
available to us as a member of the EU
and it would be available to us as a
member of the EEA and Theresa may have
said that this is not an option that
Norway's not going to happen
the Prime Minister is particularly
focused on immigration this has been
true of her in a sense
throughout her time in government as
Home Secretary and then as Prime
Minister and so it's no surprise I think
to anyone that she objects fundamentally
to the fact that the Norway option does
not control immigration in the way that
she'd like but I'm only proposing this
in the context where her deal has been
defeated and that's quite likely to
happen in ten days time now the question
is what else is there out there and the
real truth is this there is no other
option that the EU would support that
could win a majority in parliament and
get us out of the European Union on the
29th of March and for me that's the
overwhelming priority and are you
confident it could get through
Parliament than you having those
conversations yes over the last couple
of months I've been seeking out people
and all parties Labour Party the SNP
applied comer e the DUP Liberal
Democrats as well as Conservatives and
just in recent weeks people have been
seeking
and that ranges from you know many
members of the cabinet to leaders of
some of the other parties and it's
because they all see that at the moment
we might be heading off the cliff we're
gonna do a Thelma Louise and drive
straight off the cliff into the sunset
and that's not something that almost
anyone really wants to see and they do
see the potential of the Norway option
to get us out of the EU and avoid no
deal so how many members of the cabinet
you talking about it well I've spoken to
probably now six or eight members of the
cabinet I don't want to say that they're
all completely signed up to this as a
plan-b I mean of course they're all
supporting the Prime Minister's plan
first and foremost some of them are very
committed to it amber rod has been very
clear before she went back into the
cabinet that this was her preferred
fallback option others you know are
thinking it over but what is true of
everyone is that they're all looking for
that realistic doable negotiable
deliverable brexit deal and there aren't
any others if the Prime Minister's deal
is defeated and just take you step back
from the kind of intricacies of the
options on the table
you represent a seat that for many
people is almost synonymous with
conservatism it's where Margaret
Thatcher was born are you worried about
the Conservatives party image at the
minute with all of this rouse or the
brexit well there's no question the
Conservative Party is not a happy family
at the moment and we're not behaving in
a particularly adult or harmonious
fashion and and Margaret Thatcher would
be you know taking us all off no end I'm
sure for that the key thing is that we
need to be able to get beyond it and
soon we that's why I think a second
referendum would be so disastrous
because the whole country would carry on
arguing about this and in families and
in workplaces people would be falling
out with each other as we went through
the whole argument all over again do you
agree with your colleagues who say that
after brexit is they hope done next year
it's time for Theresa May to hand over
to a new generation of Ulster
I think we're definitely going to need
to have fresh faces new ideas and new
leadership before the next election I
think it should be up to tourism a to
decide precisely when she wants to hand
over my own view would be that it can't
be just before the next direction there
needs to be a decent period for someone
to be able to demonstrate what their new
approach and their new ideas would
deliver for the British people so I hope
that she would see mission completed on
the 29th of March as the time to start
thinking about when it is that she wants
to hand over to a successor